[Musique]
bonjour je suis jessica j'ai 30 ans et
je suis passé d'un poste à
responsabilité dans une grande
entreprise internationale à baroudeuse
en sac à dos globe trotteuse en fait je
suis parti pendant un an toute seule à
travers treize pays en amérique du sud
en océanie et en asie du sud est tout
seul
seul au monde et là généralement quand
on entend ça un voyage autour du monde
seule la première réaction qu'on entend
souvent cwa un tour du monde mais ça
doit être génial mais pas tout seul
ben non pas tout seul pourquoi pas tout
seul et bien parce que la solitude ça
fait peur ça fait peur pas seulement
pour voyager ça fait peur dans la vie en
général
personne ne veut être seul moi même
j'avais une hantise de la solitude et si
je vous disais aujourd'hui que la
solitude
ça peut être en fait tout le contraire
de l' isolement qu en fait au lieu de
nous isoler de nous séparer des autres
elle pourrait permettre de nous
connecter à nous mêmes et du coup aux
autres mois durant ce voyage j'ai
expérimenté une solitude créatrice
plutôt que destructrice j'ai fait un
voyage intérieur
un voyage autour du monde mais c'est
surtout dans ce voyage intérieur que
j'ai envie de vous emmener aujourd'hui
donc on va partir ensemble dans ce
voyage vous allez voir que la première
étape de ce voyage c'est bien bien avant
le premier avion qui m'avait emmené en
malaisie à l'époque la première étape de
ce voyage c'est le déclic
qu'est ce qui a été un déclic dans ma
vie pour que je décide de lui donner un
tournant radical de renverser toute ma
vie parce que j'avais un cdi
juste après une promotion j'ai décidé de
le quitter
j'ai rendu mon appartement à paris et
mon chat a atterri dans les pattes de ma
grand mère
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'à un moment
donné j'ai eu ce déclic
moi le premier déclic ça a été après une
rupture amoureuse
vous allez me dire des ruptures
amoureuses on en a tous dans notre vie
sans que forcément on décide d'aller
s'expatrier au bout du monde mais cette
rupture
- ça a été la première fois en fait que
j'expérimente est la solitude
voilà c'était sept ans de vie commune un
projet de fiançailles à la poubelle et
puis d'un coup un peu me suis retrouvé
tout seul cette solitude elle a été
imposée
je n'ai pas choisi et du coup avec cette
solitude bon bah là il ya tous les
clichés qu'on peut se faire de la vie de
célibataire qui apparaissent donc la
noirceur du tableau
voilà la tragédie du fantasme qu'on se
fait de quelqu'un qui est célibataire
mon dieu et mange tous les soirs tout
seul personne ne l'attend tous les soirs
pas de projets voilà bonjour la déprime
sauf que on peut décider de sortir la
tête de l'eau et de voir d'envisager les
choses autrement
comme je vous le disais pour la première
fois j'étais toute seule même si j'ai
toujours été très entourées de ma
famille de mes amis là je me retrouvais
quand même au quotidien tout seul et
bien en fait cette solitude qui m'a été
imposée eh ben ça a été l'occasion de
faire un point de faire un point sur ma
vie à un moment précis
voilà un moment précis un moment t j'ai
fait une photo de ma vie et je me suis
dit bon alors aujourd'hui j'en suis ue
où est-ce que j'habite est là et là ça
me donnait envie de tout remettre en
question les motivations pour mon
travail qu'est ce qui me donne envie de
me lever chaque jour est-ce que je suis
heureuse c'est important de se poser
cette question à des moments de faire un
point de se poser pour cela être pour
cela posé et qui est ce que j'aimerais
être qui je voulais être quand j'étais
petit et que je me disais oh là là moi
quand je serai grande rage aimerait bien
être
trois petits points qu'est ce qu'ils
sont devenus ces trois petits points et
qu'est ce qu'ils sont devenus votre
petit point donc c'est important à un
moment donné de faire de faire ce point
et puis d'un coup on se rend compte que
ma finalement j'ai des rêves qui refont
surface
ces trois petits points j'ai peut-être
envie de les réaliser finalement et là
d'un coup il ya un champ de liberté qui
s'offrent à nous un espace de liberté on
se dit pourquoi pas pourquoi est ce que
j'irai j'essaierai pas d'aller réaliser
des rêves
hélas la deuxième étape de ce voyage le
deuxième
la deuxième escale pour faire ensemble
c'est la conscience du champ des
possibles l'ouverture de toutes les
possibilités
alors moi j'avais plusieurs rêves
j'avais un rêve qui était très lointain
c'était de faire un grand voyage dans le
monde
j'avais déjà passé six mois en indonésie
et puis comme beaucoup de personnes
passionnées par le voyage j'ai essayé de
repartir ponctuellement dans l'année
voilà j'habite au sri lanka au mexique
en islande en finlande à madagascar sur
des courtes périodes toujours quelques
semaines et là là je m'étais dis moi
j'aimerais prendre le temps sur du long
terme
aller à la rencontre des gens on va la
prendre le temps de découvrir les pays à
voir ce luxe du temps en fait ne pas
avoir de date de retour précise ça
c'était un grand rêve que j'avais puis
j'avais un deuxième rêve plus
professionnel celui ci met des rêves on
peut en avoir tout notre vie c'est pas
que des rêves d'enfants qui sont
importants des rêves on peut en faire
quand on veut dans la vie
et moi ce rêve professionnel que j'avais
c'était de présenter des petits
documentaires voyage pour enfants alors
moi j'avais une carrière dans le monde
de l'enfance
et puis dans les divertissements les
médias et je m'étais dit bah voila moi
je trouve que que les enfants qui mérite
d'avoir des petits documentaires qui les
intéressent au monde du voyage aux
découvertes si c'est fait de manière fun
et accessible
on peut intéresser ses enfants alors bon
j'avais absolument aucune expérience ni
en tant que présentatrice ni en tant que
vidéaste ni en tant que réalisatrice ni
en tant que rien du tout dans la vidéo
mais voilà j'avais ce rêve et je me suis
dit pas pourquoi pas pourquoi est ce que
j'essaierai pas maintenant que j'ai
cette chance et ce champ des
possibilités en face de moi
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai resserré pas au
moins de faire un premier pas vers ce
rêve est donc c'est là où j'ai décidé de
partir j'ai décidé de partir sur mes
économies
j'avais économisé 15000 euros j'ai vendu
ma voiture et donc je suis parti sur ce
budget là voyager pendant un an autour
du monde et donc cette solitude elle a
été fondamental pour que cette création
émergent pour que je me mesure la
possibilité d'aller atteindre ce rêve
est donc là ça y est si le moment le
saut dans le vide
on prend notre premier avion ensemble
alors vous voyez je vous l'avais dire le
voyage finalement il a commencé bien
avant le premier avion alors
retire en solo oui mais pas tout seul je
vous raconte en fait le fait de partir
en solo ça ne veut pas forcément dire
qu'on va voyager tous les jours de la
vie tout seul je suis pas parti m'isoler
sur une île déserte c'était pas ça
l'idée est en fait ce voyage durant ce
voyage je n'ai jamais rencontré autant
de personnes d'autant de pays différents
que cette année et ça a été un
fantastique et ment aux bonnes âmes que
ce soit auprès des locaux que j'ai
rencontré kim ont pris très rapidement
sous leur aile
parce que finalement voir une nana toute
seule avec son énorme sac à dos et bien
finalement
eh ben ça ça m'a intrigué puis il y
avait un petit peu d'empathie de
sympathie et voilà j'ai eu je rencontre
énormément de personnes de tout horizon
et puis aussi les voyageurs j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de voyageurs parce
que sur les routes on n'est pas tout
seul et j'ai souvent fait un bout de
chemin avec des voyageurs donc non je
n'étais pas tout seul dans ma solitude
et puis à autre chose c'est que j'ai
décidé de partager mes reportages mais
découverte auprès des enfants bien sûr
en france
et puis aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que je me disais autant voir si
mes vidéos fonctionne donc on va les
mettre sur les réseaux sociaux
et alors là il ya quelque chose de
fantastique qui s'est créée et une
véritable communauté qui a émergé et qui
a suivi mon voyage est alors souvent on
entend des choses plutôt négatif sur les
réseaux sociaux sur sur les dérives des
réseaux sociaux
moi je peux vous dire qu'il ya des
choses extrêmement belle qui arrivent
des réseaux sociaux des choses
extrêmement positive parce que en fait
les relations que j'ai eu avec ces gens
là qui ont suivi mon voyage
elle n'était pas du tout virtuel elle
était bien réel et le soutien que j'ai
reçus étaient était bien réel quand je
suis en bolivie dans un dortoir de 15
personnes affectées d'intoxications
alimentaires énormes
ben là je peux vous dire que je le
message que j'ai reçu il était bien réel
souci parce que j'ai tout partager mes
émerveillement comme mes galères sauf
que malgré tout au quotidien il faut
faire des choix et ses choix on les fait
en solo ou est-ce que je vais dormir
qu'est ce que j'ai mangé ou est-ce que
je vais et tous ces chats tous ces choix
là il faut les faire
et là pour la première fois j'ai
découvert une des merveilles du monde
mais alors c'est pas celle que vous
pensez la merveille du monde
c'est pas le machu picchu c'est
l'intuition ça ça met ça a été ma
première grande merveille découverte
parce que finalement la première
question qu'on me pose sur mon voyage
c'est au sujet de ma sécurité à l'âme
était parti tout seul une femme seule
si longtemps en voyage mais ce n'était
pas dangereux [ __ ] et en amérique du
sud
alors oui c'est vrai j'ai bien été en
amérique du sud
j'ai remonté du chili jusqu'à la
colombie en passant par la bolivie le
pérou et l'équateur sens qui m'arrive
aucun incident alors hormis un petit
tremblement de terre léger en equateur
mais hormis ça j'ai pas eu d'incident
pourquoi et bien parce que j'ai fais
confiance à mon intuition tous les jours
de ce voyage et jamais elle ne m'a
trompé en fait l'intuition là tous en
nous sauf que au quotidien on ne
l'utilisent pas parce que dans notre
quotidien tout est passé au scanner de
notre entourage et de nos familles de
nos amis les petits choix comme les
grands choix
ce qu'on a envie de manger à la cantine
la couleur notre écharpe ou bien si on
doit démissionner voilà les gros choix
les petits choix tout est passé au
scanner de nos amis sauf que quand on
est en voyage tout seul au bout du monde
la seule personne à qui on peut faire
confiance c'est soi-même et là on est
obligé de s'écouter et cette petite voix
qui semble rien fait dans notre
quotidien d'habitude et bien là le prend
toute son importance
moi je me rappelle très bien une des
premières fois où j'ai expérimenté cette
intuition
j'étais en thaïlande et je m'apprêtais à
rejoint gte au laos et je m'apprêtais à
rejoindre la thaïlande et j'ai rencontré
à la aux siens à qui j'ai fait part de
mon projet mais petit bout du monde sur
les enfants que j'aime et rencontrer
dans le monde et pour partager avec les
enfants en france
il m'a dit on mais super tac à venir
voir ma j'ai créé une école dans mon
jardin pour tous les enfants de mon
village qui ne vont pas à l'école qui
sont déscolarisés et alors là
concrètement je dis bah oui mais il faut
faire quoi il dit bah tu viens je
t'emmène on y va
donc l'idée c'était de partir sur sa
mobylette sans fard sans casque à 80 km
de là où j'étais et je le connaissais
depuis dix minutes
si j'avais passé ça au scanner de ma
famille
et de maman et de mes amis la soeurette
et mon dieu faut pas y aller sauf que là
je me suis dit je pense qu'il faut que
j'y aille
et aujourd'hui encore ça reste un de mes
plus beaux un de mes plus beaux moments
de voyage parce que j'ai découvert
quelqu'un qui avait vraiment créer une
école et il m'a prouvé qu'il existe dans
ce monde
une humanité inspirante et cette
intuition
on l'a tous en nous on l'a tous en nous
sauf qu'on l'utilisent pas les animaux
ils ont cette intuition là aussi cessé
leur instinct de survie ils ont un
instinct animal
nous on l'a aussi on n'exploite pas au
quotidien il ya un deuxième une deuxième
merveilles du monde que j'ai découvert
durant ce voyage c'est le pouvoir de
recevoir des ondes positives et ça c'est
énorme comme merveille du monde
parce qu'en fait avec le sourire on peut
tout avoir le sourire c'est le meilleur
passeport pour entrer dans la vie des
gens et leur le fait de recevoir toutes
ces ondes positives parce que quand on
en voit on en reçoit c'est comme un
boomerang permanent et je peux vous dire
qu'en fait quand on décide de voir la
vie du bon côté
ça paraît tout simple on entend ça
depuis la nuit des temps voir la vie du
bon côté mais je vous assure que quand
on fait l'exercice parce que ça peut
être un exercice d'orienter son regard
sur les choses positives plutôt que
négatives vraiment d'un coup tout change
tout change dans notre quotidien
je dis pas que j'ai pas eu de galère il
ya eu des galères dans mon voyage
s'étaient pas à tout rose tous les jours
je pense que voilà quand on se fait
courir dessus par plein de cafards dans
une vie à la hâte dans un aéroport ça
fait pas rêver
manger des mygales en asie et du cochon
d'inde au pérou a priori ça fait pas
rêver
une bestiole qui nous pond sous la peau
en sortant de la jungle
a priori ça fait pas rêver et puis voilà
faire 30 heures de bus entre une
bolivienne qui mange du poulet et un
allemand qui ronfle a priori ça fait pas
rêver non plus mais moi si je choisis de
le partage avec vous avec ce côté drôle
et bien c'est un choix parce que moi
j'ai envie de me rappeler de ses galères
de manière positive de positiver là
dessus et ça en fait c'est un choix
qu'on peut tous faire
einstein il dit dans la vie on a deux
choix faire que
si tout était un miracle et faire comme
si rien n'était un miracle et s'ils ont
choisi la première option
je vous assure que la vie elle devient
plus belle ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'ai pu expérimenter essayer
de regarder les choses positives alors
souvent on me demande depuis que je suis
rentré peut-être que même vous vous avez
envie de me poser la question est alors
le retour à la réalité à 3 souvent ça me
fait sourire parce que en fait j'étais
les deux pieds dans la réalité
auparavant durant ce voyage avait les
deux pieds dans une réalité elle était
simplement différente de celle d'avant
mais aujourd'hui je choisis que cette
réalité elle sera tout aussi belle que
celle de mon voyage et je vous le dis
tout de suite il ya pas d'atterrissage à
ce voyage moi j'ai décidé de ne pas
atterrir
parce que le voyage que j'ai entamée
finalement c'est un voyage aussi
intérieure qui est beaucoup plus long
que ce voyage d'une année est en fait
ces merveilles du monde là qu'on
découvre on peut les appliquer dans
notre quotidien
ce matin on s'est réveillé bon il y
avait du brouillard clermont ferrand
c'est à nous de choisir si on se dit ce
paysage là vraiment c'est déprimant
aujourd'hui ou si on décide de trouver
un côté mystérieux à cette église qui
transperce le brouillard et toutes ces
petites notes de poésie et bien vraiment
si on fait l'exercice de regarder les
choses de cette manière là il va
vraiment la vie en est plus jolie donc
d'une solitude imposée est née une
solitude désiré est fondamentale pour
que cette création émergent et cette
solitude elle a été créatrice de lien de
liens envers les gens je suis parti en
solo mais pas tout seul
elle a été créatrice de découverte
découvert personnel et aussi elle m'a
appris à avoir un nouveau regard sur les
choses
je dis pas qu'il faut absolument être
seul pour découvrir tout ça simplement
quand la solitude nous tombe dessus
et bien c'est à nous d'en faire quelque
chose de positif plutôt que de rester
enfermé dans la négativité je dis pas
non plus il faut absolument la
rechercher tout le temps cette solitude
quand on est en famille en couple c'est
merveilleux il suffit simplement de ce
challenge et est en fait le voyage
permet de ce challenge et parce qu'on
sort de notre zone de confort et en
sortent
de cette zone de confort et bien voilà
on peut se tester tester notre intuition
tester voilà tout ce qui nous permet de
nous sentir vivant en tout cas je vous
souhaite à tous de découvrir vos
merveilles du monde et je vous souhaite
un bon voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]